we're all adults here I would hope that
yeah
we've reached a point in our lives where
we can buy our own clothes I'm de Lisa
I'm from Houston Texas and I used to
play hide and seek with my imaginary
friend and I never won hi I'm Chris I'm
from Philadelphia and my favorite pasta
is spaghetti hi I'm Elena I'm from Ohio
and one time I won a whole year's worth
of free ice cream
[Music]
that's really hard I don't know how to
gauge this like the questions are gonna
have to be very strategic did you ever
get like a bomb Easter basket yes yes
I don't celebrate Easter is a majority
of your wardrobe hand-me-down clothes no
no no I'm already [ __ ] up was your
house the Hangout house no no oh oh this
might be good
can you play Monopoly buyers like did
you play Monopoly as a child yes yes yes
[ __ ] down to one did you have your own
room no yes no I think that helps what
your friends describe you as a loud
person
hell yeah my friends would yes yes I
feel like I'm not doing a good job
Guinea can I get a lifeline come on
your parents have a lot of like report
cards and stuff like that yeah yes yeah
yeah because they're a help growing up
did you argue a lot with your family
yeah no no I guess like did you get a
lot of presents for Christmas no no no
yes I guess
yeah okay it was the reason why I think
this person is the only sibling because
the entire time all of us were talking
they're like more laid-back this could
be totally wrong and they could just be
a very shy person but I think it's you
Sara
that is super interesting way to
determine it but I think the chances of
someone sharing a room with a sibling
are pretty high based off of that I'm
gonna say you are an only child
I hope I'm right I'm gonna have to go
with oh yeah I am you are the only I can
do it in my last guest it's you it's me
I'm over this my question was do you
ever ever bunk bed